chantal est tout heureuse d'envoyer une
carte cadeau de 150 dollars à sa fille
florence qui vit loin de chez elle mais
quand florence reçoit l'envoi c'est la
déception
il s'agit d'un sac de plastique de
postes canada à l'intérieur
l'enveloppent de sa mère éventré sans
carte cadeau avec aude excuses de postes
canada franche et sa mère se rend au
bureau de poste ce qu'elle apprend la
concerne
même si elle a pris la peine de placer
la carte cadeau dans une enveloppe
matelassé postes canada n'est pas
responsable de sa perte
parce que chantal l'a envoyé par la
poste régulière en effet il faut choisir
un service qui inclut une assurance pour
que postes canada nous couvrent pour la
perte ou le dommage d'un envoi comme le
courrier recommandé priorité ou
xpresspost est encore là postes canada
ne couvre jamais les cartes cadeaux pour
un montant supérieur à 100 dollars
chantal aurait donc dû envoyer deux
cartes cadeaux le fin mot de l'histoire
ou lui de tenter votre chance prenez un
service avec une assurance
[Musique]